9122 2373 0689 email Islam the rof.net
for more information log on to our
website
www.ir f.net
[Music]
alhamd good morning ladies and
gentlemen it is indeed a matter of great
pleasure and
pride for all the citizens of
hii to have among us today Dr Zakir
naak I take this
opportunity to
welcome Dr Zakir
nyak and the dignitaries from all walks
of the life on behalf of the
organizers AA educational
Society it's very kind of Mr hurani a
senior Advocate to have accepted to
Pride today's function Mr K
hurani advocate for last 45 years in
bandi he was president of bandi bar
association for last 6
years and he has in-depth studied
comparative
religion our chief guest of the day
prabakar hegr personality is well known
to B people people he is a leading
lawyer of State for last 50 years he was
also member of the law commission and he
is Pioneer of the legal aid and L adalat
which was first held in bandi at the age
of 75 years he is still an active
Advocate and ideal for aspiring young
Advocates he has written books for the
guidance of the junior practicing lawers
on subjects like bail and
injunctions as veteran Congressman he
was District Congress president and also
vice president of
mpcc presently he's busy defending T
victims in
Bombay our main speaker Dr Zakir nyak
president of Islamic Research Foundation
is a dynamic International orator on
Islam and comparative religion he's the
main driving spr by alhamdulillah behind
the Islamic Research Foundation getting
worldwide a claim for the proper
presentation understanding and
clarification of Islam as well as
removing misconception about Islam
though a medical doctor by professional
training he has turned around to spread
the real truth of Islam worldwide
especially amongst millions of
englishspeaking
audience at only 32 years Dr Zakir
explains the teachings of Islam and
Killers misconceptions convincingly with
the help of Reason logic and science he
has tremendous ability to quote
extensively and W him from Holy Quran
and other religious scriptures
Dr Zakir is renowned for his critical
analysis and his spontaneous and
convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by the audiences and
Skeptics about his public talks in open
question and answer
sessions he has delivered more than 200
Public talks in the last two years
itself in United States of America
Canada United Kingdom Saudi Arabia bahin
UAE Kuwait Qatar Sri Lanka Malaysia and
Singapore in addition to many public
talks in India he has also participated
in Symposium with prominent
personalities of all the other Faith Dr
Zakir has appeared on various
International TV programs and satellite
and TV channels programs in United
States of America Malaysia India
Etc he is regularly qu and interviewed
by the media worldwide especially on why
Islam conflicts with issues of women's
right human rights modern science and
secularism but his Dynamic resolve to
dispel media myths about Islam with
facts specific
references and proper context stand out
to rectify or neutralize the Prejudice
or media bias if any based on
unwarranted presumption or conclusion
more than a 100 of Dr Zaki lectures
debates and symposia available on video
and audio cassets are popular he has
authored books on Islam and comparative
religion
alhamdulillah wasam
sh
[Music]
respected Advocate
Hegde respected Advocate
hingorani my respected elders and my
dear brothers and sisters I welcome all
of you with the Islamic
greetings
allum may peace blessings and mercy of
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of
you the topic of this morning's talk
is
universal
Brotherhood there are various
types of brotherhoods for example
brotherhoods based on blood
relationships Brotherhood based on
regions on Race on cast on Creed
Etc but all these types of Brotherhood
they are
limited Islam alhamdulillah believes in
Universal
Brotherhood it doesn't
believe that human beings have been
created in casts or in different
levels and I start my talk by quoting a
verse from the Glorious Quran from Surah
huat chapter number 49 verse number 13
which describes the Islamic concept of
universal Brotherhood in the best
way it
says which means that oh
humankind we have created you from
single pair of male and
female and have divided you into Nations
and tribes so that you shall recognize
each other not that you shall despise
each other and the most honored in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is the
person who has
tawa and
Allah is all knowing full of knowledge
and well acquainted with all things
this verse of the Glorious Quran says
that oh humankind we have created you
from a single pair of male and female
that means the whole human race
originates from a single pair of male
and female all the human beings in the
world they have a common
grandparent and Allah subhana tala says
that we have divided the human race IND
and tribes so that they shall recognize
each other not that they shall despise
and fight amongst
themselves and the criteria for judgment
in the sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
this ver is doesn't depend on sex cast
color creed or wealth but it depends on
tawa that is God Consciousness that's
piety that's righteousness anyone who
who's more righteous who's more Pious
who's more God conscious is honored in
the sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
Allah has full knowledge and is well
acquainted with all
things further the Glorious Quran says
in Sur Room chapter number 30 verse
number
22 that and amongst his
signs is the creation of the heavens and
the Earth
and the variation in your languages and
your
colors verily in that is a sign for
those who
know the Glorious Quran says that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has created various
types of languages and different colors
black human being white brown
yellow and these ass signs these
variations in colors and language is not
to despise each other
because every language that you have on
the face of the Earth it's a beautiful
language it may sound funny if it is
unique to you you may not have heard
that language before it may sound funny
but those people who speak that language
for them it's the most beautiful
language so Allah says he has created
various languages and colors so that you
may recognize you may know each other
and the Glorious Quran says in Surah
isra chapter number 17 verse number
17 that Allah subhana wa ta'ala almighty
God has honored the children of Adam
Allah doesn't say that he has honored
only the Arabs or the Americans or a
particular race but almighty God has
honored all the children of Adam
irrespective of race cast color creed or
sex and there are many faiths there are
many religions who believe that the
humankind has originated from a single
pair that is Adam and Eve peace be upon
them but there are some faiths which say
that it is because of the sin of the
woman that is Eve may Allah be pleased
with her that the human beings are born
in
sin and they put the blame only on the
woman that is Eve for the downfall of
the human beings in fact the Quran
speaks about the story of Adam and Eve
peace be upon them in several places but
in all the
places the blame is equally put on both
of them Adam and Eve peace be upon them
and if you read Surah chapter number 7
verse number 19 to 27 Adam and Eve peace
be upon them they addressed more than a
dozen of times and the Quran says that
both of them disobeyed Allah subhana wa
ta'ala almighty God both of them
repented and both were
forgiven both are equally blamed for the
mistake there is not a single verse in
the Glorious Quran which puts the blame
only on Eve may Allah be pleased with
her but there is a verse in the Glorious
Quran inah
chapter number 20 verse number 121 which
says that Adam peace be upon Him
disobeyed Allah subhana wa
tala but if you read the Quran both are
equally blamed for not obeying Allah
subhana wa taala they both repented and
they both were forgiven and certain
faiths they say that because if
disobeyed Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
responsible for the sin of humankind
which Islam doesn't
agree Allah subhana wa ta'ala cursed the
woman and said that she will bear labor
pains that means pregnancy is a curse
According to some people which Islam
doesn't agree at
all and thear recited the words from the
Glorious Quran from Surah chapter number
four verse number one which says respect
the womb that bore you in Islam
pregnancy does not degrade a woman it
uplifts a
woman and the Quran says in Sur lukman
31: number 14
that oh
humankind we have enjoined on you to be
good to your
parents in travail upon travail did your
mother bore him and in your Twain was
his Ving the Quran says in Surah 46
verse number 15 we have enjoined on the
human beings to be kind to the
parents in pain did his mother bore him
and in pain did she give him birth
pregnancy uplifts a woman it does not
degrade
her and in Islam men and women are
equal and according to a Hadith which is
mentioned s bukari volume number eight
in the book of adab chapter number two
Hadith number two a person came to the
prophet Muhammad Sall Ali wasallam
Muhammad peace be upon him and asked him
that who is the person who deserves the
maximum love and companionship in this
world and the prophet said your mother
the man asked who next the prophet said
your mother the man asked after that who
the prophet repeated for the third time
then the prophet said your father in
short 75% 34 of the love and
companionship of the
children are due to the mother
25% 1/4 of the love and companionship
goes to the father in short the mother
gets the gold medal she gets the silver
medal as well as the bronze medal the
father has to be satisfied with the mere
consolation
prize these are the teachings of Islam
in Islam men and women are equal but
equality does not mean
identicality there are many
misconceptions especially when women are
concerned in
Islam many Muslims and non-muslims they
have
misconception which can be removed if
you understand the authentic sources
Quran and the S Hadith correctly as I
mentioned men and women are overall
equal but equality does not mean
identicality let me give you an
example that if in a class of students
two students student A and B they come
out first and both acquire 80 marks out
of
100 but if you analyze the answer
sheet there
are 10 questions each carrying 10 marks
in the first answer student a gets n out
of 10 student b gets seven out of 10 so
in question one student a has a degree
of Advantage than student B in question
two
student b gets n out of 10 and student a
gets seven out of 10 in question two
student B has a degree of Advantage than
student a in the remaining eight
questions both get eight out of 10 and
if you total the marks of both the
students both get 80 out of 100 so if
you analyze both student A and B are
overall equal but in the answers to some
questions student a has a degree of
advantage in answers to some questions
student B has a degree of Advantage but
overall both are equal similarly in
Islam men and women are equal
Brotherhood in Islam does not only mean
that the same Sexes are equal the
universal B in Islam means that besides
race cast and Creed even the sex are
overall equal men and women are equal in
Islam but in some aspects the men have a
degree of advantage
in some aspects the woman have a degree
of
Advantage but overall both are equal for
example if a robber enters my
house I will not say that I believe in
women's rights I believe in women's
Liberation therefore my sister my wife
my mother should go and fight the
robber because Allah says in Surah 4:34
that Allah has given men more strength
than the other that men have more
strength than the women so so where
strength is concerned the men have a
degree of Advantage so since they have
been given more strength it's their duty
to protect the wom here the men have a
degree of
Advantage where love and companionship
is
concerned where children should give to
the
parents the woman have a degree of
Advantage as I mentioned earlier the
mother gets three times more respect and
companionship than the father here the
women have a degree of Advantage but
overall if you analyze men and women are
equal in
Islam and for more
details you can refer to my video
cassette I'd given a talk on women's
rights in Islam modernizing outdated
it's part
one there's the lecture and part two
this is a question answer
session these discuss the issue in great
detail and many misconception which are
there in the minds of the human being
have been removed here and in this
talk I've divided the wom's rights in
Islam under six broad headings spiritual
rights economic rights social rights
legal rights educational rights and the
political rights and I've described
there that overall men and women are
equal the concept of Almighty God in
Islam of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is not
that almighty God Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is the diety of a particular race
or a particular group of people but the
Quran says in Surah fat chapter number
one verse number two
alhamdulillah praise be to the lord of
the
worlds almighty God is referred
as the lord of the
worlds and in the last Surah of the
Glorious Quran
that
is Surah Nas chapter 114 verse number
one it
says let say I seek Refuge with the Lord
of
humankind almighty God Allah subhah wa
ta'ala is the lord of the whole of
humankind not of a particular group of
people or a particular
race and there are various wordss in the
Glorious Quran which Begin by saying
oh
humankind oh
humankind and even the two verses I
quote in the beginning of my talk they
began
with oh
humankind
and the Glorious Quran also says in
Surah Bak chapter number two verse
number
168 oh
humankind eat of what is on the Earth
good and lawful for you and follow not
the footstep of the devil for he is to
you an AOW
enemy Islam in order for Universal
Brotherhood to Prevail in the world it
has a moral code it has a moral law
which helps in Universal Brotherhood
prevailing throughout the world
throughout the
Universe the Quran says in Surah MAA
chapter number 5
verse number 32
that if anyone kills a person unless it
be for murder or for spreading Mischief
in the land it is as though he has
killed the whole nation all the
people and if any person
Saves a Life it is as though he has
saved the whole of humankind all the
people the Quran says that if any person
kills any human being whether it be a
Muslim or non-muslim it doesn't specify
the race or cast or color or Creed if
any person kills any human being unless
it be for murder or for spreading
Mischief in the land it is as though he
has killed the whole of humanity and if
anyone saves a human
being whether it be a Muslim or
non-muslim from any cast color or Creed
it is as though he has saved the whole
of humankind
the Quran has
various laws of moral
conduct so that Universal Brotherhood
will prevail throughout the
Universe the Glorious Quran says that no
one should ever Rob it's a crime it's a
sin Islam has a system of zakat that is
any rich person who has a saving of more
than the nisab level 85 G of of gold he
or she should give
2.5% of that saving every lunar year in
charity if every human being in the
world gives zakat poverty will be
eradicated from this world there will
not be a single human being who will die
of hunger and the Glorious Quran says
that you should love and help your
neighbors the Quran says in Sur ma
chapter number 107 verse number 1 to7
that Fe is Town not the person who
denies the day of
judgment
and Deals the often with harshness and
encourages not the feeding of the
Indigent woe to those who are neglectful
of the prayers V to those who pray only
to be seen of men who do not even
provide provide neighborly assistance
the Quran says that woe to those people
who do not even provide neighborly
assistance and our beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam said
that he is not a
Muslim who sleeps with his full stomach
while his neighbors are
hungry that
means any person who sleeps with his
full stomach that means had a good meal
while his neighbors are hungry is not
following the Commandments of Allah and
his
rasool the Glorious Quran says that do
not be a
spendthrift the Quran says in Surah is
chapter number 17 verse number 26 and 27
that do not squander your wealth like
that of a spendthrift for verily
spendthrifts are the brothers of the
evil one of the
Satan if you are a
spendthrift you
abound to disturb the universal
Brotherhood because but natural if a
person scers it creates animosity it
creates
enemity it creates Envy between the
brothers a person should not rob a
person should give charity a person
should provide neighborly assistance all
these are moral conducts mentioned in
the Glorious
Quran the Quran further
says that you should not bribe the Quran
says in Surah Bak chapter number 2 verse
number 188 that spend not your wealth on
when it is and do not use it as a bait
for
judges in order you may eat somebody
else's property that means do not use
your wealth to bribe the people so that
you may eat up other people's wealth
Islam doesn't agree in eating up your
brother's
wealth and the Glorious Quran says in
Sur Ma chapter number five verse number
90 oh you
believe most certainly intoxicant and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper the Glorious Quran says
that abstain from having intoxicant
alcohol drugs from G Ling from
dedication of stones divination of
arrows all these are Satan's handwork
and we know that in
toxicant is one of the root cause for
various evils in the
society it prevents the universal
Brotherhood from
prevailing and according to statistics
it tells us that in
America on average every day more than
1,000 900 cases of rape take place and
in most of the
cases either the victim or the
rapist is
intoxicated the status of America tell
us that there is 8% of incest in America
that means every 12th or 13th person you
come across in America he has committed
incest that is having sexual
relationship ship with closed relatives
father and
daughter son and mother brother and
sister and majority almost all the cases
it's under the state of
intoxication AIDS is spreading in the
world one of the reason is intoxicant
therefore the Quran says intoxicant and
gambling it's a Satan's handiwork
abstain from this handwork that you may
Prosper if you abstain from these evil
things Universal Brotherhood will be
helped in prevailing throughout the
Universe the Glorious Quran says in
Surah is chapter number 17 verse number
32 nor come close to adultery for it is
a shameful deed it's an evil opening
other roads to evil Islam is against
adultery the Glorious Quran says in
Surah huat 49 verse number 11 and 12
that
that oh you believe let not some men
among you laugh at the others you may
never know that the latter may be better
than the former let not some woman among
you laugh at the other you may never
know that the latter may be better than
the
former do not defame one another nor be
sarcastic or call each other with
nicknames avoid suspicion for in many
cases
suspicion is a sin do not spy on one
another do not backbite do not speak ill
of one another behind the backs are you
ready to eat the dead meat of your
brother the Quran says that if you back
bite if you slander anyone behind the
back it is as though you are eating the
meat of your dead brother and eating the
meat of your dead brother is a double
sin eating dead meat itself is
prohibited eating meat of your dead
brother is double crime even the
cannibals who eat human beings they do
not eat the Flesh of their brother so if
you back bite if you speak ill about
somebody else behind the back it is a
double crime it is eating the meat of
your dead brother and the Quran gives
the answer Allah subh says n you would
it no one would ever like it
the Quran says inza 104 verse number
one to every kind of Scandal monger and
back
biter all these laws of moral conduct
given the Glorious Quran and had they
promote Universal
Brotherhood besides talking about
Universal Brotherhood the uniqueness
about Islam is that it practically
demonstrates the universal
Brotherhood the Muslims are supposed to
demonstrate the universal
Brotherhood five times a day in the
Salah when we offer Salah we practically
demonstrate the universal
Brotherhood it's mentioned in s
bukari volume number one in the book of
Adan chapter number 75 Hadith number 692
that we pleased with him he said that
when we stood for Salah the shoulder of
the companions touched with the shoulder
of the companion our feet touched with
the feet of a companion the Beloved
Prophet said it's mentioned Abu da
number one in the book of Salah chapter
number 245 Hadith number 666 AB beloved
Prophet said before starting the Salah
that straighten your
roles stand shoulder Tosh shoulder and
do not leave any gap or opening for the
Devil the prophet said stand close to
each other during Salah and do not leave
any opening for the Devil the prophet
was not referring to the devil which you
see in the on TV ad you know the on TV
ad the Devil with the two horns and a
tail the prophet was not referring to
that devil he was referring to the devil
of racism of cast of color of wealth
irrespective whether rich or poor
whether king or propa when you stand for
prayers when you stand for Salah stand
shoulder to shoulder so that
the Brotherhood increases the devil of
racism of cast of color of greed of
wealth does not come in between
you and the best
example of International Brotherhood
is in the pilgrimage of Islam that is
during
Hajj about 2 and a half million people
from various parts of the world
they come to Makkah to perform Hajj
people from various parts of the world
from America from Canada from UK from
Singapore from Malaysia from India from
Pakistan from Indonesia from various
parts of the world they come and the men
they're dressed up in two pieces of
unsown cloth that prefer will be white
you cannot identify that the person
standing next to you whether he's a king
or a
poer it's the best example example of
International Brotherhood it's the
biggest annual Gathering of the world 2
and a half million people gather every
year and the person standing next to you
you cannot make
out whether he's a king or a
papa irrespective whether rich or poor
black or white from whichever part of
the world you're coming you're dressed
in the same
attire and our beloved Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam said in the
speech of his fav pilgrimage he said
that there is only one God and no Arab
is superior to a
non-arab nor is a non-arab superior to
an
Arab a white is not Superior to a black
nor a black over the
white the only criteria for superiority
is tawa it's righteousness it's piety
it's God consciousness
irrespective whichever race you belong
to whichever color you have that doesn't
make you Superior in the sight of Allah
all are equal only if you're more Pious
more God conscious more righteous can
you be superior to the other human
being
and when the Haj is performed every
person he recites
they keep on
repeating even when he comes back from
Haj that always remains in his
mind which means here I am oh my Lord
here I
am I am you have no Partners here I
am all all Praises are due to you all
bounties are
yours to you belong the whole
Dominion the whole universe and you have
no Partners it is ingrained in his mind
that here I am oh my Lord here I am and
the Cornerstone of the Islamic faith
is the belief in one and only soul
Creator and sustainer of the entire
universe he alone deserves
worship and it is because of belief in
one God that they can be Universal
Brotherhood that means the same God has
created all the human beings
irrespective whether you're rich or poor
whether a male or female whether black
or white whichever cast color creed you
belong to all of them are equal because
you are created by one and only soul
whole Creator almighty God only if you
believe in one God can you practice
Universal
Brotherhood that's the reason that all
the major religions which believe in the
concept of God on a higher level they
believe in the existence of one almighty
God and according to walks for
dictionary religion means a belief in a
superhuman controlling power a God or
gods that deserve worship and obedience
so in short if you want to analyze any
religion you have to understand the
concept of God in that
religion and the best way to analyze the
concept of God in any religion is not by
looking at what the followers are doing
because many of the followers themselves
do not know what the religious
scriptures speak about almighty God the
best ways to analyze what the scripture
of that religion has to speak about
almighty
God and the Glorious Quran says in Surah
Al Imran chapter number three verse
number
64 say oh people of the
book that come to come in terms as
between us and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
Lords and patrons other than
Allah if then they turn back say bear
witness Muslim that we are Muslims
bowing our will to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala Allah shows you a way how to
speak with different people it
says that come to come in terms as
between us and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we Associated to partners
with him so in order to understand the
concept of God in any religion you have
to understand what that scripture has to
speak about almighty
God if you understand the concept of God
you will understand the
religion let's first analyze the concept
of God in
Hinduism if you ask a common Hindu who's
a lay man that how many gods are there
some may say three some may say 100 some
may say thousand While others may say 33
cres 330 million but if you ask a
learned person who's well wored with the
Hindu scriptures he will tell you that
the Hindus should actually worship only
one God and they should believe only in
one God but the common Hindu he believes
in a philosophy known as
pantheism what the common Hindu says
that everything is God the tree is God
the sun is God the Moon is God the
monkey is God theing is God the snake is
God what we Muslims say that everything
is God's g o d with apostrophe yes
everything belongs to God the tree
belongs to God the sun belongs to God
the moon belongs to God the monkey
belongs to God the human being belongs
to God the snake belongs to God so the
major difference between the Hindus and
the Muslims is that the common Hindu
says everything is God we Muslims say
everything is Gods God o with apostrophe
the only difference is
apostrophe if we can solve this
difference of
apostrophe the Hindus and the Muslims
will be United how do we do it Quran
says
that come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah the most common scripture which is
the most widely
read by the Hindus is the bhagwat Gita
if you read bhagwat Gita chapter number
7 verse number 2 it says that all those
whose intelligence has been stolen by
material desires they worship Demi gods
that means means those whose
intelligence has been stolen by material
desires they worship Gods besides the
one true
God and if you read the upanishad which
is another sacred scripture of the
Hindus it's mentioned in the Chanda
upanishad chapter number six section
number two verse number
one there is only one God without a
second it's mentioned in
thead chapter number six verse number n
which means of him of almighty God there
are no Lords neither does he have any
parents it's mentioned
thean chapter number four verse number
not of him there is no
likeness it's mentioned the chapter
number four verse number 20 that he has
got no form no one can see him with the
eyes among the scriptures of the Hindus
the most sacred are The Vedas the
basically
fouras the the the Sam and
the if you read the it's mentioned in
chapter number 32 verse number
three of him there is no image almighty
God has got no
images it's mentioned the your chapter
number 40 verse number 8 that almighty
God is bodyless and pure and the next
verse of yaj chapter number 40 verse
number n says
that that they are entering Darkness
those who worship the asui asui means
the natural things like air water fire
and the wor continues they are entering
more in darkness those who worship the
STI STI are the created things like
chair table Idols Etc who says that J
chapter number 40 verse number
n further if you read it's mentioned in
the chapter number 20 himym number 58
verse number three da Mahi verily great
is almighty
God amongst the
wayas the most
secret is
the it's mentioned
rade book number one hymn number 164
verse number 46 that sages and saintly
people call almighty God by various
names and if you read rade book number
two himym number one there are various
attributes given to almighty God one
amongst them it's
mentioned book number two hymn number
one verse number three
Brahma if you translate Brahma into
English one of its meaning is the
creator if you translate into Arabic it
means
khik we Muslims have got no objection if
someone calls almighty God as khik or
Creator or Brahma but if someone says
that Brahma is almighty God who has got
four heads and on each head is a crown
we Muslims take strong objection to it
moreover you're going against punish
chapter number six verse number n which
says of him there is no likeness you're
giving an image to almighty
God another beautiful attribute given in
r book number two hymn number one verse
number three is Vishnu if you translate
Vishnu into English one of its meaning
is the sustainer the chisha if you
translate into Arabic it means Rob we
Muslims have got no objection if someone
calls almighty God as r or sustainer or
cherisher or wishnu but if someone says
that Vishnu is Almighty called who has
got four hands and one of his hands is
the chakra The discus and one of his
hands is the Lotus we Muslims take
strong objection to it moreover you're
giving an image to almighty God you're
going against J chapter number 32 verse
number three which
says of him there is no image
it's mentioned in R Vol number eight
chapter number one verse number
one all Praises are due to him alone
worship him
alone it's mentioned in
R volume number six himym number 45
verse number
16 there is only one God worship him
alone and the Brahma Sutra the
fundamental Creed of Hinduism is
there is only one God not a second one
not at all not at all not in the least
bit so if you read the Hindu scriptures
you should understand the concept of God
in
Hinduism let's analyze the concept of
God in
Judaism it's mentioned in the book of
Deuteronomy in the Old Testament
chapter number 6 verse number four Moses
speaks be upon me says
that it's a Hebrew quotation which means
is the Lord our God is one
Lord It's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 43 Verse number 11
I even I Am Lord and besides me there is
no
savior it's mentioned in the book of
Isaiah chapter number 45 verse number
five I Am Lord and there is none else
there is no God besides me it's mention
in the book of Isaiah chapter number 46
verse number N I am God and there is
none else I am God and there is none
like
me it's mentioned in the book of
Exodus chapter number 20 verse number 3
and 5 as well as the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 5 verse number 7 to9 it
says
that thou shall have none other God
besides me almighty God is speaking here
besides me thou shal not make unto thee
any Graven image of any likeness of
anything in the heavens above in the
earth beneath and in the water beneath
the Earth thou shall not serve them nor
bow down to them for I thy God is a
jealous God so if you read the Old
Testament you should understand the
concept of God in
Judaism before I discuss the concept of
God and Christianity I would like to
make a few points clear that Islam is
the only non-Christian Faith which makes
it an Article of Faith to believe in
Jesus peace be upon
him no muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus peace be upon him we
believe that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah wa tala of almighty
God we believe that he was the Messiah
translated Christ we believe that he was
born miraculously without any male
Intervention which many modern day
Christians today do not believe we
believe that he healed those born blind
and lepers with God's permission we
believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's
permission the Muslim and the Christians
we are going together but there are some
Christians who say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he claimed
Divinity in fact if you read the Bible
there is not a single unequivocal
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus peace be upon him himself says
that he's God or where he says worship
me in fact if you read the Bible Jesus
peace be upon himself says it's
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 28 my father is
greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than All gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse number 28 I cast
out Devil with the spirit of God Gospel
of Luke chapter number 11 verse number
20 I cast out Devil with the Finger of
God Gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of my father anyone who
says that I seek not my will but God's
will it means he's submitting his will
to almighty God and if you translate
into Arabic it means Islam and anyone
who submits his will to almighty God he
called as a
Muslim Jesus peace be upon him he never
came to destroy the law of the prophets
in fact he came to confirm
them and Jesus peace be upon Him says
it's mentioned in the go goel of Matthew
chapter number 5 verse number 7 to2 he
says that think not that I am come to
destroy the law of the
prophets all these quotations from the
Bible from the King James version this
pleas be upon Him says that think not
that I am come to destroy the law and
the prophets I am come not to destroy
but to fulfill for verily till the
Heaven and the Earth pass not one jot or
tit shall pass away from the law until
all be fulfilled and whosoever shall
break one of the least Commandments and
teach men to do so shall be called least
in the kingdom of heaven and whosoever
shall keep them and teach the same Shall
be Called great in the Kingdom of Heaven
unless your righteousness exceeds the
righteousness of the scribes and the
Pharisees in no way shall you enter the
Kingdom of Heaven Jesus peace be upon
Him says that if you want to go to
paradise you have to follow each and
every law
of the Old Testament including that God
is one he has got no Partners you cannot
create any images of
God and Jesus peace be upon him he never
claimed that he was almighty God in fact
he says that he was sent by God it's
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 24 Jesus peace be
upon Him says that the words that you
hear are not mine but my father's who
has sent me
it's mentioned the Gospel of John
chapter number 17 verse number three
this is life eternal so that you may
know there is only one God and Jesus
Christ whom thou has
sent it's mentioned the book of Acts
chapter number two verse number
that
is hear these words Jesus of Nazareth a
man approved of
God amongst You by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and you are witness
to it it says Jesus of Nazareth peace be
upon him a man approved of God by
wonders and miracles which God did by
him and you are witness to
it and when Jesus peace be upon you last
that which is the first of the
Commandment he repeated what was earlier
said by Moses peace be upon him it's
mentioned the gospel of Mark chapter
number 12 verse number
29 the Lord our God is one
Lord so if you read the Bible you should
understand the concept of God in
Christianity let's analyze the concept
of God in
Islam the best reply that any person can
give you regarding the concept of God in
Islam is quote to you Sur
chapter number 112 verse number 1 to4
which
says say he Allah one and only
Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal he begets not nor is
begotten there is nothing like him this
is a forline
definition of almighty God of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala any person saying that
is almighty God if that person fits in
this forand definition we Muslims have
got no objection in accepting that
person as almighty
God the first
is say he's Allah one and only second is
Allah Allah the absolute and eternal
third
is he begets not know his
begotten and the fourth
is and there is nothing like
him this suras chapter number
112 is the Touchstone of theology Theo
means god logy means study Surah iklas
chapter number 112 of the Glorious Quran
is the Touchstone of theology anyone
claiming to be almighty God if that
candidate fits in this forline
definition we accept him to be almighty
God and for the universal brother to
Prevail it's compulsory that you believe
and worship only one almighty God so
anyone claiming to be almighty God if
that person fits in this full and
definition we have no objection in
accepting that candidate as almighty
God you know there are many false people
who claim to be almighty god let's
analyze whether they pass the test or
not and one among such person is bhagan
rajnish you know there are some people
who claim that he almighty God during
one of my lectures in the question
answer time there
was a Hindu friend of ours who told that
the Hindus don't believe in bhagan as
God I told him I do agree and I've read
the Hindu scriptures nowhere does the
Hindu scripture say that bhagan dnes is
God what I said some
people say that bhagan God I know very
well that Hinduism doesn't consider
bhagan to be god let's analyze the claim
of such people who say that bhagan
rajish is almighty God the first test
is say he's Allah one and only is bhagan
Rish one and
only we know that there are several
human beings who claim to be almighty
God especially in this country there are
several such people claiming to be God
is he one and
only but his followers may say no he is
one and only let's go to the next test
Allah Allah the absolute
Eternal was bhagan R absolute Eternal we
know from his biography that he was
suffering from as from chronic back ache
from diabetes
malius and he says that the American
government when they arrested him they
gave him slow poisoning imagine almighty
God being slow
poison the third test
is he begets not no he begotten and we
know from his biography that rajnish was
born in madha Pradesh he had Parents
mother and father who later on became
his own disciples and in the year
1981 rajnish goes to America and takes
thousands of Americans for a
ride and in the state of Oregon he
starts his own village known as
rajuram later on the American government
they arrest him and they put him behind
bars and in 9 85 he is deported he is
sent out of the country he comes back to
India in 1985 and the City of Puna he
starts his own Center Doo commune and if
you go there it's
mentioned on the stone there that bhagan
rajnish oo rajnish never born never died
but visited the Earth from the 11th of
December 1931 to the 19th of January
they forgot to mention that he was not
given visas to 21 different countries in
the world Imagine almighty God he is
visiting the Earth and requires
visas and the last
test there's nothing like him is so
stringent that no one besides Allah
subhana wa ta'ala almighty God can pass
the moment you can compare almighty God
to anyone in the world to anything in
the world he's not God for example if
suppose someone says that almighty God
is a thousand times as strong as an
swasher you know AR waser the person who
was given the title Mr Universe the
strongest man in the
universe if someone says that almighty
God is a thousand times as strong as
Hest waser the moment you can compare
almighty God to anything in this world
whether it be aner or King Kong or daras
Singh whether it be a thousand times or
million times the moment you can compare
almighty God to anything in this world
he is not almighty
God there is nothing like him this is a
four-line definition of almighty God
given in the Glorious Quran which is the
Touchstone of
theology otherwise the Glorious Quran
says in Surah is chapter number 17 verse
number
am say call upon Him by Allah or by
Rahman by whichever name you call upon
him to him belongs the most beautiful
name you can call Allah subhana wa tala
by any name but it should be a beautiful
name it should not conj up a mental
picture and there are no less than 99
attributes given in the Glorious Quran
for Allah subhana wa taala Alman Alim
most merciful most beneficient no less
than 99
we Muslims we call almighty God by the
Arabic name Allah and the reason we
prefer calling almighty God but the
Arabic name Allah instead of the English
word God is because the English word God
you can play Mischief with that word for
example if you add s to God it becomes
God's PL of God there is no plural of
Allah say he is Allah one and only if
you add D SS to God it becomes Goddess
that means a female
God there is no gender to Allah subhana
wa ta'ala he's neither male neither
female Allah subhana wa ta'ala has got
no gender Allah is a unique word if you
add a father to God it becomes Godfather
he's my godfather he's my guardian
there's nothing like Allah father or
Allah B Islam if you add a mother to God
it becomes god mother there's nothing
like Allah mother or Allah mean Islam
Allah is a unique word if you prefix tin
before God it becomes tin God meaning
fake God there's nothing like tin Allah
in Islam that's the reason we Muslims we
prefer calling Allah subhana wa ta'ala
by the Arabic word Allah instead of the
English word God but if some people some
Muslims use the word God for Allah
subhana wa ta'ala so that those who
don't know the concept of Allah subhana
tala if they can understand I've got no
objection but the appropriate word is
Allah it's much more preferred than the
English word
God in
Islam the universal Brotherhood does not
only spread
horizontally that is it doesn't only
cover all the regions and all the people
of the whole world and universe it even
goes
vertically the universal Brotherhood in
Islam the universal Brotherhood of Faith
includes vertically even the generations
that came before you that went in the
past the universal Brotherhood in
Islam includes the people living and the
people of past you are a single
race you a single
people this Universal
Brotherhood that is the Brotherhood of
faith it spreads horizontally as well as
vertically
and the Cornerstone of this faith in all
the religions if you analyze it is the
belief in one Creator one almighty God
it is only because of this that
Universal Brotherhood can Prevail in the
whole
universe and this Universal Brotherhood
of
faith it is far superior to the
Brotherhood of Blood
relationships the Quran says as I
mentioned you should respect your
parents the Quran says in Surah is
chapter number 17 verse number 23 and 24
that Allah subhana tala has ordained for
you that you worship none but him and
that you be kind to your parents and if
any one of them or both of them Reach
old age do not say a word of contempt
don't even say of to
them but lure to them your wing of
humility and address them with honor and
pray to thy Lord that cherish them as
they cherished me in
childhood that means you have to love
and respect your parents and give them
all honor and
respect but at the same time the
Glorious Quran says in Surah lukman 31:
number 15 after saying that you have to
respect the parents the Quran says but
if they strive in making the join
partners with me who you have no
knowledge of that means if your parents
force you to join partners with almighty
God you do not obey them but in this
world deal with them with Justice and
compassion that means your parents you
have to obey them as long as they don't
go against almighty God against the
Commandment of Allah subhana wa taala
you have to obey them if they go against
the Commandments Allah subhana wa ta'ala
almighty God is more Superior the
Brotherhood of faith is universal it is
far superior than Brotherhood of Blood
relationships and the Quran says inah
number 9 verse number
24 say whether it be for your
fathers or your
sons or your
brothers or your spouses your husbands
and
wives or your relatives Allah is asking
what are consideration is it your
fathers are they your sons your brothers
your spouses husband and wives are they
Rel it is if all these things for
example your father or your sons or your
brothers or your spouses or your
relatives and Allah
continues the wealth that you haveed the
business in which you deal the house in
which you live Allah is saying what your
consideration what are your
considerations and Allah continues
that if you love all these eight things
more than Allah his rasool and doing
Jihad striving in the way of Allah Allah
says if your parents tell you to go
against Allah subhana wa ta'ala they may
tell you to Rob they may tell you to
cheat they may tell you to bribe they
may tell you to kill people
unnecessarily if your parents give you
guidance against the Commandments of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala whether it be
your sons whether it be your brothers or
your spouses or your relatives or you do
de s against Allah subhana wa ta'ala for
the wealth that you are collecting the
business in which you deal the house in
which you Delight Allah says if you love
all these eight things more than Allah
his messenger and striving in the way of
Allah Allah says
wait wait until Allah brings about his
decision unto you until Allah brings
about destruction to
you and Allah guides not the the
transgressors why it comes to
Brotherhood of faith it is far superior
to Brotherhood of
relationships and further the Glorious
Quran says inaha chapter number 4 verse
number 135
that oh you believe Stand Out firmly for
justice as witness to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala even if it be against yourself
against your parents against your
relatives whether it be rich or poor for
Allah protects both
that means if you have to stand for
justice as giving shahada as giving
witness to Allah subhana wa ta'ala Allah
says stand for justice even if you have
to speak against yourself against your
parents against your relatives
irrespective whether the people are rich
or poor for Allah protects all that
means where it comes to
Justice where it comes to truth justice
is far superior to blood relationships
the Brotherhood of faith supersedes all
the other
Brotherhood and the Brotherhood of Faith
the universal Brotherhood is based on
the basic concept of believe in one
Creator one almighty God one Allah
subhana wa ta'ala which is preached by
all the
religions and the Quran says as I
mentioned earlier in Surah Al Imran
chter 3 verse number 64
that come to terms as between us and you
which is the first
term that we worship none but Allah only
believing in one almighty God is not
sufficient you should also worship only
one almighty God and only if you believe
and worship almighty God whose one will
Universal Brotherhood
Prevail without the concept of one
almighty God Brotherhood and Humanity
cannot Prevail in the full world and the
Glorious Quran says in Surah Anam
chapter number 6 verse number 108 that
revile not those people abuse not those
people who worship God besides Allah
lest in their ignorance they will revile
Allah subhana wa ta'ala I would like to
end my talk by giving the quotation of
the Glorious Quran from chapter number
four verse number one which
says that oh humankind reverence Your
Guardian Lord who has created you from a
single person and created like nature
his made and has scattered like seeds
countless men and women ald